i'm going to talk about node
unfortunately i'm not going to give so
much of an introduction to it um
because i kind of gave a rather long one
a while ago and there's this video on
the internet so
i kind of figured like if you want to
know about it you could you could watch
that
that video and i don't really want to
waste your time so much
so here's my introduction slide
node is a server-side javascript
platform
it's built on v8 and
it's really good at handling lots of i o
at the same time and not necessarily
like lots of server connections
it does that fine but also lots of
different types of i o like
standard input and standard output and
a unix socket and a tcp socket and files
and just kind of all of this different
io
all at the same time um
and it does this um in a way that's not
at all new
it's what twisted and what event machine
do
which is making the network i o
non-blocking
and using an event loop um
yeah and the file i o is is asynchronous
um which is a little bit new so it has a
built-in thread pool so that
um whenever you call like some blocking
system call on on some file which system
calls usually are on on
actual hard drive files it actually goes
to a thread pool so
you you kind of get this complete
non-blocking environment
um and so just a very
simple demonstration this
is a little program that listens
starts a web server and starts a tcp
server at the same time
and the web server is listening on port
8000 and the the
tcp server servers listing on port 8001
and when you connect to the web server
you get hello world
and when you connect to the tcp server
it tells you how many people have
connected to the web server
just just an example that you can
throw multiple lots of different types
of i o
into the same program rather easily
um right so so here's a here's a
reference to
uh the other video so i want to talk
about
speed actually um in node because it's
it's pretty important like everything is
speed actually if if the program's not
fast then it's
it's basically worthless and um
i think uh it's important to
to make an environment like this
that is supposed to be for writing
servers and stuff
as fast as it possibly can be so
um what i want to do is
is try to describe to you how node
is fast and maybe some things that are
not fast about it
um just kind of put a realistic
perspective on
you know what is this this node thing
and really
how fast is it um and so to do that
uh i'll give some a couple of benchmarks
and
i'll benchmark against nginx which is
um a web server written in c
uh and is really really quite fast
and uh
maybe there's the possibility of a
faster web server
um but i think we can take in genex as
kind of
like the baseline this is what is
possible
and you probably can't get much better
than that um
and then we'll we'll benchmark node and
then we'll benchmark two
uh web servers for
dynamic languages which is tornado
and thin tornadoes
python thing and thin is a ruby thing
and i just did it on this on this laptop
um
these these benchmarks aren't really
meant to be
real necessarily it's not trying to
simulate like
actual what would happen on a website um
because basically we're going to hit it
with more load than
is achievable on a single like network
device
um all all four of these web servers can
saturate your bandwidth right they're
they're all quite fast
what we're interested in is is more
about how they perform under
very high load levels and just see if we
can bring out any
problems with with them
so let's let's just start with the
standard like hello world
uh web server um and what we'll do is
is we'll just hit it we'll hit each of
these with apache bench and
um look at how they differ with
different amounts of concurrency
so hopefully you can see this i'm not
sure if it okay
looks visible um so so here's
here's the the the three control
servers right nginx is on the bottom
okay wait so so concurrency is
is the horizontal axis that's how many
people are connecting at the same time
and
uh the vertical axis is response time so
you want to be
fast you want to be lower down on the
graph so smaller is better
so so engine x looks really good it's at
the bottom
as expected thins somewhere in the
middle and and tornadoes a bit
slower again the actual numbers here
aren't
really so important because they're
probably not
uh you probably can't achieve this sort
of load actually
in real life but the point is
nginx is quite a bit faster than than
the other ones
by a factor of two or three so if we add
node into there
then it looks like this which is
good i would say it's not really
comparable to nginx
but it's it's looking good when compared
to thin
um
so now let's let's let's do another
benchmark
and um instead of just sending a hello
world response
what we can do is is fix a concurrency
and
and vary the response size so
you know send a five kilobyte response
send a 10 kilobyte response and see how
the web servers
uh deal with with these different
amounts of throughput basically
um and so so
well ignore that bottom line here's oh
wait okay
yeah so so basically this is this is
what the node web server would do
um this is for 16 kilobytes so you you
just generate some
some string of data and then you you
when somebody connects you write that
string to the socket so this would be
for for 16 kilobytes but we're going to
vary the amount of response size
okay so so again here's the control
servers
uh and uh again
response time is is on the vertical axis
and
nginx looks really good and it's it's
approximately
the same as what we saw before you know
thin is in the middle
tornadoes a little bit slower um
and engine x is at the bottom so let's
let's add node into this picture um
remember
here this is two to the 18 so that's
like 256 kilobytes
or something like that and this is
you know your basic hello world program
so you know they slow down as you
as you as they send larger responses
so let's let's add note into this
picture
um and i'll
let you grasp this for a second this is
not good
that's a bad spike that's not a good
spike
down here they look okay
we can't really see but it's pretty
similar but as
as we start getting into large response
sizes
note sucks right
node really sucks um
you're you're that was like three
seconds over three seconds for for a 256
kilobyte response it's terrible
it's not rails terrible right
i mean this this is at
300 uh concurrent users at the same time
okay rails would be off the map here but
it's not
it's it's a different order of magnitude
than these other servers
they're doing something right and node's
doing something wrong
so so what's what's actually happening
here
well v8 the the virtual machine that
node runs on has this
is very complicated and has this
generational garbage collector so
it moves data around inside of its own
heap
and so um v8 won't actually give you
a pointer to the data like the actual
data of a string
you have to copy the data out of v8 into
your own
heap outside of the v8 heap and then you
can write it to socket
so every time node writes something to
to a socket
it copies it out of v8 and then copies
it to the socket
so i think in the other
web servers they can take strings and
write them directly to the socket
so to address this problem um
i've added a a buffer object to
to node which is very simple it's just
um it's a chunk of memory it's a chunk
of memory that's outside of
v8's heap that um you can modify
and write directly to the socket
and so this is what what the example
would look like with a with a buffer
you know it's it's binary data so um
it doesn't look very string like but you
can fill it with data
so so here where we create a 16 kilobyte
buffer
and then we write it to the socket so
let's look at the benchmark with the
buffer
now things look okay actually things
look really okay
over here with with the buffer node is
basically
matching nginx for speed which is which
is pretty impressive considering that
you know nginx is this highly optimized
c
program and node is this completely
dynamic
you know thing sitting written in
javascript
written sitting on top of this virtual
machine
so so that's good um
yeah so so so these buffers are pretty
fast
like node can push these these buffers
directly to the socket and and it can it
can do it
very well so if if we just go back here
and we just took like a cross section
right here at like the
256 kilobyte case and and just looked at
a histogram of of
of these response times here just to
get an idea of of how this looks um
now response time it's a histogram so
the response time is on the
on the horizontal axis here so you want
to be
over there that's fast this is slow
and engine x has this this great spike
here
meaning it's fast and
node has a larger variance which is not
so good
but it's it's getting in very fast
responses
it's also getting in some slow responses
too the slow end is
is equivalent to the fast
end of of thin and tornadoes kind of
out there
so but the fact remains i mean if if you
just took the
the hello world program that's on uh
the node website and and you you know
adapted that to to write out a large
string to the socket
it's going to be slow and and it's kind
of
unacceptably slow um so hopefully this
this can be fixed in the future um
you know what what might have to happen
is is
we might have to modify v8 so that you
know if if v8
doesn't want to uh give us a pointer to
the data inside their heap which is
completely reasonable since they're
moving around at all that
they're moving around these objects you
know maybe we can
give the right system call to v8 and say
hey
v8 here's this file descriptor can you
write that
string to the socket and just let it
deal with
with its own memory issues so that that
might be a way to to
solve the problem
anyway so the this buffer uh it's pretty
simple
and it's one of the new features in node
it's what you would expect it's just a
very simple c buffer you can
you can allocate it and you can adjust
the values and you can
encode strings into it and then decode
strings out of it so if you actually
have like a big file that you want to
write to the socket
it's probably good to allocate a buffer
for it write the file into the buffer
using this and then write that buffer to
the socket many many times
so like for a static file server that
would definitely be the way to go
importantly you can't resize buffers
though so they're not completely string
like you can't just kind of append
values to them
um yeah chris chris has been talking
about having some
like higher abstraction on top of
buffers which would be totally possible
where you could
you know just append strings and stuff
but under the
underneath it would be it would be
buffers that that would be possible
we'll see
how it turns out um
right and so since since
the 1.90 release of node which
was a couple weeks ago node is
is mostly written in javascript now it
used to be um
back when i when i gave the talk last
november that that most of node was
was kind of c and it just kind of had
this this thin
binding layer and so most of
the algorithms that node used
to push data to the socket and and all
of the stuff that i was doing was
basically opaque because it was kind of
inside
this the sea realm that people don't
really want to touch
um and it's it's hard to modify i mean c
c is a hard language to just manipulate
and so
um now now most the the the binding
level is much lower
it's basically at the posix layer where
you just kind of
bind certain calls and then the rest is
written in javascript
and this is working out really well
um so so part of the rewrite was was to
get this buffer thing
that we needed because getting strings
out of v8 was so slow
um and also just because
you know strings aren't really an
appropriate data type in javascript for
binary data
i mean you can pack arbitrary binary
data into
strings but it's just somehow it's it's
not right for that
um but the other part of the rewrite
in addition to just kind of making
things more javascript friendly
um was was to unify this concept of
of string streams so
node had all these all these different
objects which which would stream data um
but they they they had different
interfaces so like you had a hdp request
object and it emitted this body event
you know if somebody's uploading a movie
to you it's a body body body
and you'd get various chunks of the body
and for a
hdp response object you would have the
send body function so you could
you could send stream data back to the
to the user
and a tcp socket had a receive method so
when you got when you got data on on the
tcp socket it would say receive
receive receive and then it had a send
method to send data
you know it's like the postsix calls
that made sense at the time
and and uh standard io had like this
data event
when you read stuff from from standard
in and it had this this write event to
write to standard out
and you know kind of very slowly
in my very like sloth sloth-like mental
capacity like
i came to realize that huh maybe maybe i
should like not
be making up new names for all of these
different things
every time we came up with a new
stream um
and the more i thought about it again
very slowly
um that like unifying these streams
would be very cool
because if we did that we could we could
actually do polymorphism like we
we could we could write general purpose
functions that dealt with streams that
could like do things
in particular we could write like a
general purpose
pumping function that would take data
from one stream and pump it into the
other one
and we could actually do this in a
really good way with all the proper
throttling and stuff
and it could be all on one event loop
and we could just get a callback when
we're done with it
so maybe you somebody's uploading a file
and you just pump it to the standard out
if you want to see what it is or you
pump it to a file
or you pump a file into a into a
response
pumping data throughout a process is a
very common thing and it would be nice
if we could just
put it into a single function basically
so the the stream interface which i will
describe to you is split into
two parts uh it's readable and writable
streams
some streams are both readable and
writable they're duplex
so like a like a tcp socket so the
readable stream looks like this
it has a data event you receive data and
it says data data every time it's
it's continually pulling in data and
when you get an eof
or a fin packet on tcp or
whatever if if maybe it's a fake stream
maybe it's
maybe it's an http request in a
pipelined
http connection so it's not actually the
end of something
but you have an end event when this data
terminates and then you have you have
some things for throttling so you can
pause that you know
stop i can't deal with more data right
now i have to do some other stuff and
resume
and then a destroy method which would
just kind of terminate
everything it would close the underlying
socket it would say okay i can't i don't
want any more events right now
and the the writable stream um
has a write method basically um it has a
write method and an
end method so you write data and then
you end it
and then for for the purposes of
of you know the the the kernel right
buffer might fill up
and at that point the write method is
supposed to return
false and then you would listen for a
drain event so you write all this data
it all fills up
and you say you know i can't the kernel
can't handle pushing out more
data to the interface right now and so
you just wait for that to drain down and
then
you get this drain event and then you
can fill up the the buffer again
so i mean with with this drain and
this read this pause and this resume
you can actually you know take data from
here
and pump it into there and then when
this one returns false from right
you know because the the the buffer is
filled up
then you say pause okay i can't handle
anymore over here
and you know wait till wait till this
data flows out here you know if you're
pumping something from a very fast
connection into a very slow connection
this is likely that will happen so
you need to be able to handle the these
sort of
throttling issues um
yeah so just as an example there's lots
of these streams inside nodes so
like standard input would be a readable
stream and a server
request would be a readable stream like
somebody's uploading a movie to you that
would be
something readable and and if you launch
a child
process the pipe into that child process
to the child processes standard out that
would
be a readable stream right because the
child process is writing stuff
and um and then the opposite for the
writable streams
um yeah the stream interface i mean
it i think it needs to grow a bit
organically
there's probably more that needs to be
added so
for example there probably needs to be
some sort of low water mark for
for writable streams to
to say when when they should when they
should actually drain so that
so that they don't um push data out to
the socket immediately
okay so uh what else is happening so um
for rather technical reasons node had
this
udns library that used to do
asynchronous dns lookups
dns is extremely complicated like
there's no way i could possibly write my
own dns library i
i would like to but it's it's infeasible
so um i was using this udns
um and that's been replaced with with a
similar library called see aries
and when we did this rewrite of of these
streaming interfaces we used to use
new tls for the for the um
in the c code but but now we're going to
switch it out with openssl
which is um a bit more available and uh
you know usually you have open ssl
installed on your computer whereas
you don't usually have new tls
um but the side effect is
the these two these new tls and udns
kind of run um they they were both
lgpl libraries and um
with this replacement um
all of the libraries that node uses and
node itself is is
um rather simply licensed this last
sentence isn't correct 100
mit bsd i mean openssl has this apache
sort of license but it's
it's rather okay and openssl
is kind of this big understood library
so
this is only good if you're like some
company and you like
can't touch gpl code at all
well now node is pretty free from that
um another thing that that was done
recently was
was a repo library um
which we had already but you could only
do it on standard i o
now you can do the repo library on
arbitrary sockets
so you could start a tcp server and put
the repo
on the tcp server so you could telnet
into your process
and examine what it's doing but that's a
bit dangerous you probably
rather want to open a unix socket
and telnet into that unix socket
but this is cool right you can have a
running web server and you can telnet
into it and inspect variables while it's
running
and it can completely demonize in
everything and and be
detached from a tty um so yeah here's
here's an example of of um
of starting uh the repo on a um
on a unix socket it's pretty trivial
just copy those three lines of code into
your program
um and then
there was this other thing this promise
dot wait
so node had this thing where when you
did like a file
operation you it returned a promise and
then i had this this weird thing where
you could wait on that
and it would make the the
the it would make the operation seem
synchronous in that
instead of having to do a callback after
that file operation because it was
asynchronous
you could wait on it and would just
return the value and then right under
that you could do the next line of code
as if nothing had happened but it wasn't
really synchronous it was just kind of
faking it it was switching to a
different
execution stack and calling other events
and then when it was done it would
switch back to the original execution
stack
this was a terrible idea
co-routines suck like
don't listen to brian mitchell they're
they're terrible
we don't have these in the web browser
right
you don't you don't have multiple
execution stacks in the web browser you
get
events you call functions and then you
return to the event loop
and then another event happens it would
be terrible
if you were in your web browser
environment and you called all these
functions and then kind of like in the
middle of your call to jquery
somebody else called a button clicked a
button and then that event started
while your other stuff was like being
paused
and then that other button event you
know screwed up all the state of
of what was happening in the original
function call
in the original event and then when you
return back to this original function
can you follow me at all probably not
i'm just waving my hands
um the state is all messed up there
you have to thinking about co-routines
is hard because you at any function call
you have to be prepared for the fact
that io
can like somehow happen somebody you
know i'm going to call this function and
then in some library down the line
somebody's going call wait and it's
going to jump to the event loop
and then i o is going to happen so if i
just have a parser and i'm like parsing
a socket happily and then i call a
function
and then suddenly like you know
now more data comes in on the socket and
and my parser starts on that data and
then when i return to my original
function like
the state of my parser is completely
different what would have to happen if
we had co
routines is we would have to have locks
around the parser we would have to be
really careful about what
the state of of where of what we were
doing and we had to make sure that when
you called a function that you were
aware that there was a possibility that
anything is going to happen at that
point it's not as hard as
as thread safety co-routine safety is
easier
in thread safety you have to worry about
these atomic issues i mean
in co routine safety you can you can
copy an array to
some place and it's not going to to cut
right in the middle of that array
copy copying but it's still difficult
let's just make life easy okay it's it's
hard enough no co routines
let's just have events we'll call some
functions and then it'll be done
the co routines don't add anything if
anything they make our program
perform worse the only thing that they
do is
give you this kind of you know
pleasure of having like these calls one
after another
which i agree is is kind of nice but
it's just not worth the mental anguish
so cooperative threading of any sort
is a terrible idea um the other thing
that's going on
is um yeah the project is growing and
now we have a build bot
which does continuous builds and and
runs all the tests
and it even like does performance tests
just like in the chrome project so on
every commit
it runs a set of benchmarks and displays
it on a website and so we can see
if we commit something if suddenly that
makes the rest of the
project slow and we can revert that
commit
um
yeah so so um yeah the project's growing
um there's been a lot of interest in it
there's been 42 releases and there's 63
contributors
it hasn't grown that much in code size
mostly because of this
rewrite um but we've got over a thousand
people on the mailing list and
thousand people on github that are
watching it so
so it's it's nice um yeah
are there any questions what's the
threshold for the
drain event right now what is it
i mean you mentioned lowering the water
iron map what is it right now
if any it writes to the socket
immediately so
so you're going to to as soon as you you
write something to a socket it flushes
it
it tries to flush it
yes where does module dynamic module
reloading stand right now
um reloading dynamically reloading
modules like hot reloading of modules
like
you know when you're in ruby on rails
and you update some code and then
you know you go back to the website and
it's changed
this is hard this is really hard to do
like i thought this would be
fairly simple but it's not um and the
problem is
you you're just kind of carrying around
these javascript references and you just
can't you can't really switch out the
implementation from underneath them
there's been several attempts none of
them are very
satisfactory to me
there's some new development going on in
v8 which does
uh live editing uh kind of at
at a very low level which um i think is
the proper way to go
for for doing this sort of thing so i'm
i'm waiting for v8 to figure it out
yes how do you think the stable api is
going to affect the amount of modules
uh right so so so i want to stabilize
the
api very soon now um i
i want to do this at a 0.2 release i
mean i can't completely like say i'll
never change it again but i
i want to like not change it every day
okay and i want to like
thank you
so so there's there's been a lot that
needs to be done that's why i change it
all the time
um i hope that that uh when
i reach this 0.2
which should be in a couple weeks i've
been saying that for weeks and months
but
it will be in a couple i wanted to have
it done for for this conference but it's
not
um i hope that that people will start
building modules
on top of node at that point
huh more modules please yes
there are some of them
okay that's it thank you
you